oh justine what are you doing oh are you
dancing because you have the best dance
moves ever yes that's actually what i
was doing you guys all know how awesome
of a dancer i am you've seen me dance in
apple stores
you've seen me dance on the third street
promenade
you've seen me dance in clothing stores
you've seen me dance in grocery stores
but i'm thinking bigger here i think i
need to dance on dancing with the stars
now what you're thinking is justine
you're not actually a very good dancer
well that's where you're wrong because i
have potential and with potential
comes
well
something better you can train anyone to
be a good dancer but what you can't
train someone is to have enthusiasm and
obviously if you can't tell i've got a
lot of enthusiasm and i just don't know
what to do with it that's why i dance so
if you guys would like to see my sweet
sweet dance moves on dancing with the
stars i'm gonna need a little bit of
help from you favorite this video like
this video leave comments below saying
ijustine on dancing with a star season
12 but most importantly go to voteij.com
yeah i just bought that domain today and
it forwards to a dancing with a stars
website where people are leaving
comments on who they want to be on next
season so that's what i need you guys to
do i need you to go there i need you to
be like yo what's up dwts ij for the win
ijustine season 12. we want justine's
sweet dance moves all up on the
television because really i'm running
out of apple stores to dance in i think
i need to take this show on the road